yeah and i think that's one of the
primary messages of the book is that you
describe uh children of the immigration
act of 1965 which is definitely me and
you
people whose highly educated parents
were let in when when that was the
preference
uh and then you have the more recent
immigrants who don't think of themselves
as asian american maybe often aren't
engaged politically they might not speak
english very well uh and there's a
concern of the former group that's
around cultural issues representation
and media uh politics
and the attempted
creation of an asian-american political
identity
and then there's the lived experience of
the vast majority of people who
don't have those experiences or
advantages or that sense of collective
identity people are more like your
parents maybe they'd identify themselves
as koreans in america or cambodians in
america or whatever the group happens to
be
uh and and that your
recommendation is that
asian americans in the former group the
educated group should be
taking on
the true
issues that are facing
uh the latter group which uh which
have been suffering in many ways
especially over the last number of
months like that your recommendation is
to make common cause with
uh with that group which by the way is
probably larger is that fair to say
yeah yeah i mean the example that i give
in the book and the one that i speak
about quite a bit is that like
after the georgia spa massacres right
which is this you know traumatic
experience i think an extremely
traumatic experience for a lot of asian
americans but it was about a day of
people talking about the actual tragedy
and then in the mainstream media and in
all the messaging channels like the
conversation abruptly shifts right it
becomes a lot of people like you and me
right who sort of grew up with educated
parents and had went to good schools and
now occupy these sort of elite
places talking about ourselves right and
what do we talk about we talk about like
microaggressions in the corporate
workplace right we talk about uh the
time when our i certainly do not try and
talk about those but continue
no no you did it you did i said people
people who grew up like us right um who
occupy these positions and so and then i
was thinking about it at the time and i
was like well why is this happening you
know these these people are dead right
these people
are
you know they're involved in sex work
which i'm not saying anything bad about
sex but it's a precarious life right
it's one that needs protection right um
they are all recent immigrants like
they're not people who are born here in
the united states there are people who
are living in almost in extremely
economically precarious conditions right
they're not people who like are worried
about the the way in which they're
treated at a diversity seminar for
example at google or something like that
and yet these are the narratives that
proliferate everywhere right like the
sort of upper middle class like uh asian
spokesperson asian american spokespeople
start to take over and it becomes about
them
and
i think that that is like a i think that
is a i think that's a path to nowhere
you know i think that it leads to zero
solidarity with other groups right like
i think that uh that it makes it so that
other groups think that like our
arc that that all asians have no
problems except for
what role scarlett johansson stole from
one of us you know he's like who wants
to be in solidarity with a group like
that right like if those are the express
concerns and so the book is more about
like or the argument that you're talking
about in the book is just that like look
we need to like
we need to start thinking about people
who are actually less fortunate you know
we have to think about these immigrant
communities we have to think about
the people like people in georgia who we
say we care so much about but also are
erasing from this narrative almost
immediately and replacing with us right
and so
um i think that's a very difficult thing
to do but i don't really see any other
pathway for like whatever this thing
that we call asian american identity oh
i'm gonna suggest another pathway uh you
might not like it but i'm just gonna
throw this out there
so in a way it's like ronnie chang's
recommendation where he talked about how
we're going to be the referee
[Laughter]
so you have a country that's coming
apart and i'm going to propose that
asian americans become the glue that we
become the unifying group that's trying
to solve the real problems keep everyone
together
and when you talk about who we fight for
i mean i love the idea of trying to
elevate and embrace the cause of recent
immigrant uh workers and part you know
because i mean that they remind me of my
family and everyone i'm sure like a lot
of people
feel the same way um but i want us to
try to make the country whole to see
like america's interests as ours and say
to folks too that if the reverse is true
if this country disintegrates which by
the way it's on track to do uh it's
going to be terrible for everyone it's
going to be terrible for us
that's that's my case i don't know what
you think i think that it's i think that
there's a lot of asian people who fill
that role right and it's like something
that i think like
yeah it's something that wesley yang
writes about too right where he talks
about how like you know like the asian
male is sort of like the every male
right because like he doesn't really
find any identification with any sort of
culture and so he just becomes sort of
the default right like i think that that
there is some in that but i also just
think that like i don't know can you
really like what do you think these
immigrant populations are going to get
right like i guess i'm just having a
hard time uh picturing like how they
would be mobilized in that sort of way
right how they would see it in their
best interest well if you look at these
immigrant populations and you described
in your book about your parents it's
like these came in and just wanted to
make a living you know some others like
wanted to like
a decent life and i think that's what
motivates a lot of folks uh you know in
in a big way
to me i i want to
create the conditions where that still
is true for people who show up and you
know they don't need to worry about
being asian and you know getting
um beaten up in some way uh it it's like
a functional america
uh it allows them to fulfill that
ambition
i suppose right right
yeah i guess i just think that that
um
for me the political work is always just
going to be about
um
figuring out ways to have solidarity
with other groups right and
uh specifically like black and latino
groups right like in in america and i
think that for
a lot of asian americans uh who are you
know in my position for example where
they're they're okay financially and um
but they are always trying to think
about themselves how am i going to fit
within this progressive space right i
think those asian americans don't
necessarily care about what white people
think about them you know i don't really
care what white people think about me
i'm 41 years old you know i'm sort of
over that right i think that the thing
that
those asian americans think about quite
a bit though is what black people think
about them right like how because they
see that as the only way to sort of have
a type of solidarity type of politics
that they can be proud of right and and
that i think that that's why there's so
much sort of like
care around some of these issues around
these attacks for example right like
people are really really upset about
saying something that they feel will be
treason us to that type of solidarity
now the contention i make in the book is
that that sort of solidarity is very
fraught right like that that outside of
places like the academy or outside of
places like i don't know corporate
boards or something like that or
diversity spaces like it's not it's it's
very difficult to say that it's there
you know if you're having a new
conversation about in in the new york
mayoral race a new phrase was coined
um which someone used people of color
and then someone said well like you know
yang's of color and they were like no no
people have more color
[Laughter]
right right and it seems like every day
a new turf is created to sort of like
push asian people out of like this
coalition right and so i think that my
say it's just like we need to just kind
of be honest about that right and if our
goal which i think should be our goal
like i mean this totally like this is
like the purpose of my life's work
basically is like can we build
meaningful coalitions with those people
can we have meaningful solidarity with
like uh black and latino when you say
that it says i would say can we build
meaningful coalitions with
people with anyone like i take anyone
you know
right right sure but like but you know
for me for me it really is like a center
around like you know like what what
would be like a sort of politics of
descent right like i'm much more to the
left than you politically right so um
and i would just say that you know you
need to start doing work that resembles
work that other people are doing right
and i think that there are a lot of
asian american activists who are doing
this type of work right now right
they're totally ignored right they're
they're sort of but they're doing work
that's like kind of like helping laundry
workers or helping bike messengers
whatever like um
delivery drivers
right right right and i mean i i think
that like early on like when you're in
your like 20s or something like that
you're pretty involved in this sort of
stuff weren't you um or like you're
involved in asian americans yeah yeah
quite quite uh quite a lot
yeah so like i think that um
that if there i just think that that
would be a much more appealing
type of work for people to do it'd be
more satisfying but at the same time and
i think that it would have a lot of
overlaps with the type of work that like
you know coalitional black latino
activists are doing as well now it
doesn't mean that you have to have all
this be determined by activists right a
lot of this is just work in your daily
life and i think that's the only path
right but it's difficult it's difficult
like the end of the book is me just sort
of expressing my own
doubts that this will ever work right
like that because we're so incentivized
by capitalism yeah well i i the takeaway
i took was was you know you present a
couple of different choices and then
you're like well you know we kind of
need to forge our own identity in our
own path which is something i agree with
[Music]
you